how's it going bros my name is hey we're
back in the machine thing of the dinger
they are Jesus Christ cogwheels Oh
anything about you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] battles what are you doing down
here
this does not sound good Oh God will I
was joking though [ __ ] oh [ __ ] cogwheels
man Jesus penis was about wasn't it I
don't even feel like screaming let's go
that a machine anyway like I I was
supposed to play the grudge today but I
don't know I feel like continuing
playing this so I don't know
mm Misha barrels already oh you [ __ ]
cog wheel holy [ __ ] oh my head how'd you
scratch barrels oh wow hello I don't
trust you
alright levers oh this is the final
level safe talked about my god
my lord last weekend ever she never knew
progress game like that Asia since a
lollipop unfortunately I lost me again
sir that I don't exactly always a game
important to combine the two levers to
open it one turns steam source on while
the second one directs is steam into the
proper engine but there's a problem
while ever opens in the door of the
library we don't know what's going on
there open
jarick the levers that's for that holy
[ __ ] I did it good job pity I'm proud of
you alright let's check that up I'm
ahead
dude strife it's kind of a control panel
it's a closet in my opinion a bit okay
I'm gonna use those later right now
check out I don't trust you
one second don't give me that stupid
face oh [ __ ]
bounce what did I do what oh oh no no no
no no no not our oil please please
please all think penis think penis all
right I'm just gonna go here Wow hello
boys and girls huh huh okay we got
dripping oil over here I think we need a
glass jar for that bounce oh [ __ ] it's
so many puzzles down here this place is
creeping me out us might
you and yeah and yeah and yeah
[Music]
so many [ __ ] apostles what do you
want happening I throw up I don't feel
good I don't feel good down here all
they say to me is about Jesus Christ
cogwheels
and [ __ ] Oh God
I've never seen many pot doors Oh period
I didn't know what shares could have
periods but apparently we can I'm almost
out of oil I should be more careful with
it and no one down here any cog wheels
that are attacking me huh
what is this I guess this will open
sooner or later I have to find my wife I
need to open bulkheads if I want to
progress oh it is it Oh a hand hello
patty want me to scratch your back for
you I could do that all right
that's agreed my people have inserted a
solid steam buckets to control their
lowered passage you can open it by
turning the bow which we have built
inside to control illnesses of course
you will need to turn this image off
first just direct the steam source to ng
number 110 X gives on as set there okay
you do you what the [ __ ] does that mean
the fact is your date what's down here
Oh God barrels down here huh what's down
here a rope box isn't [ __ ]
Oh Oh sanity potion I could use up my
shrimps and mice seriously what's the
point with this our battles trying to
Adam something from me but sorry I don't
even know maybe I need the Jennifer I
don't know Jennifer go hmm cockroach it
oh no I know this is gonna happen sooner
or later
you're on out of shop we need these okay
up you go buddy what you have any more
of those Rick's will be shot
no I think that's it bounce I hate to
Paris how do I get up though
how you just jump okay [ __ ] huh
okay let's just go up here
well I just have a pipe and don't count
me please
okay here's that's I guess I have to put
this here I don't know if I did it
correctly I need one more I suppose this
is so dark why why did I waste my
lighter hair this I could find it good
I'm a genius
all right go go pipe go haha pity now
I'll try to do this for you but all
right what do you want from me Jesus
pinion what about this come on bro
bad bet that's what she said but it's
stuck it has to be right it has to be
right now whatever I'll talk to you
thank you
what battles it was you oh wait
nevermind all right this turn is off
I can't fine let's go back to the levers
or whatever [ __ ] it ah
okay I don't even know what I'm doing
here I'm just trying to find my wife but
friend I'd have to do machinery puzzling
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] you so creepy how about
pity how you're doing
Hardin out doing my well there
all right fair enough I don't like you
very much I don't like it very much at
all
what about now maybe now it works I
don't even know anymore
I don't like these chronicle story it's
creeping the hell out of me all right
hahaha we go Ambrose I don't think I
needed a long introduction or anything
my name is Pierre back oh this is a long
introduction anyway apparently if you
put these on in the wrong order the
script doesn't work so yeah I spent
about 45 minutes trying to figure that
out yesterday it was a lot of fun I
think there's just right combination I
just do it
nice shirt but that's not the right
combination all right then it's like
this two down and one up because they're
like UD UD and I'm like yeah yeah no
it's not right come Nate
[ __ ] what did they do it on what do you
want from me maybe like this maybe like
that like this like that I heard it like
like that I'd like that
wait I think we need to go back up and
be like oh yeah we're gonna shake that
oh we got a sledgehammer something I
just want hits Oh No
huh what's going on what what wha what
was that [ __ ]
okay that was nothing I don't understand
right yeah machine is working to help a
there I love you my name is on fire I
won't forget you okay fine enough I
think we already read this out out okay
so now I haven't if you pull this no no
it Frank
every that stupid cheap chinese stuff i
do subscribe I don't trust you it's what
I do with people I don't trust
I put paddles in their hair my IRA okay
let's focus baby focus I have one more
us don't worry what is up there hey is
this your clothes before
yeah wash ye let's go up well I love
stairs I lost so much oh man stairs oh
look at their Halep Eddie
I heard you made it this fire I'm proud
of you but there's many more tests to be
tested I don't even know what I just
said but there's many more tests to
possession now if you want a hug now
would be a great time mmm just suck it
in all right sound important I left a
tip for you pretty because I figured
you're pretty [ __ ] insane right now I
mean you're talking to your share hey
now we can't go to that point
haha I tricked ya oh god am i a text why
not why why that was me right no hey how
does pity
now whatever hey what is the f why did
dad like it can I go here Oh
I want to go aired I don't think I can
it's good [ __ ] my maybe downstairs like
in the basement thing you may be
thinking hey oh I don't like this place
they don't give you a lot of oil in this
map and I don't like when it's dark
oh god what is up with this place
hello Darryl surmise what was that huh I
don't know it was guys am i I don't know
he's raping my girl
no oh [ __ ] it's just at this Nana
Oh God aside wallet yeah it's me
oh god Nina what they they do to you
right out of your breasts
there's so much as I'm always is yes sir
stupid love Helen we should ban
mannequin the Machine rating above our
heads wise it's a living mush no no you
watch push make a living machine the
kids open this damn oh damn Nina you're
so sexual to do laboratory ah inject yes
yes yes a little bit of flesh has to be
able Jesse oh yes Ashley's Dana wait
wait this isn't me not him you
wait wait this is a boy yeah uh okay
let's go back and really pay attention
what is then let's got a laboratory oh
yeah
I love Larry charge actually I don't
there's usually bad stuff in
laboratories like all right sir oh no
how about it I'm glad he made this fire
you're in the lab but right now
I'm not talking about that or do you
think I was trying I don't talk to Mara
hate them just as much as you do
and I totally get you their jokes I
don't like them like I would frame my
socks and don't judge me I like to play
with socks and they were like hey you
play with sharks on our yeah whatever
I'm a share all right then I hey let's
echo all right uh whatever how much damn
Peter Pan's gonna [ __ ] you up all right
like Noah no I don't care and then I was
like I don't even know what I just pick
up a saw
oh no I don't like that like they're
probably gonna make your sauce Jeff I
don't like that okay I just go and play
with my socks buddy
[Music]
Oh No
I spy uh-huh okay we got this
beer man